Ed up
the words
[Music]
music icon Bert back rack has died at
the age of 94.
Becker X family says he died of natural
causes at home on Thursday they were by
his side he survived by his wife and
three children ones from his previous
marriage to kale bear Sager who wrote
multiple hits with Bert
[Music]
a prolific composer Bacharach began his
career as a songwriter in the 50s and
quickly found success
Hollywood called on his talent for
iconic movies I just had first uh first
series of hits and I was walking and uh
past a hotel in London and the doorman
was whistling Alfie what all about
me he and Carol won an Oscar for
Arthur's Theme I don't sing on my albums
I never did much maybe half a song very
self-conscious about my boys his other
collapse operators music legends Barbra
Streisand The Beatles Gladys Knight
Elvis Costello
and of course Dion Warwick who he and
the late Hal David helped make a star
you're dancing four bars this lady it's
the most perfect vehicle to um
sing my Melodies always was I guess
in a statement to E.T she Mourns her
longtime friends saying we laughed a lot
and had our run-ins but in the end his
death is like losing a family member
altogether Bacharach wrote more than 500
songs nine of them chart Toppers earning
the artist every award imaginable
including eight Grammys and three Oscars
I remember the first Academy Awards that
I won one of the best feelings I've ever
felt in my life Joy leading up to the
pandemic in 2020 Bacharach was still
touring one vinyl record album Bert
Bacharach plays his hits back in the 90s
Mike Myers introduced his music to a new
generation calling on baccarat to cameo
in Austin Powers a movie that tributes
an era Bacharach helped Define ladies
and gentlemen Mr Bert Bacharach
world
needs now
[Music]
there's just now
his love sweet love
but just put songs
[Music]